well bailey i am uh i am very impressed  with you i really am you seem like  i really am you seem like a very funny  and witty and cool person  you'd be the person and sona back me up  on this i would be talking to bailey a  lot at the party  yes to the exclusion of other people uh  and we would both be trying to out  self-deprecate the other  yes and um then afterwards it'd be like  i really like bailey bailey seemed cool  yeah yeah i would yeah i appreciate that  i mean i think it's probably  the irish catholic you know boston  heritage in us both  oh do you think do you have heritage in  back in boston do you think uh well  my dad's from andover oh god that does  it oh  no yes it it runs it just it's in the  blood  yeah it's interesting we'll just one-up  each other by  going down on like how bad we are as  people  you might be related you probably are  probably are you probably my third  cousin which makes your win illegal by  the way